foreign
ER coming right at you all right all
right so you've looked you've looked up
at the night sky before I have indeed
all right and and you've been perhaps
prompted from time to time to notice
what the Press would
bill as a planetary alignment of note
there was a big one that happened that
was on the news some time ago last year
but that's what I'm saying it was so
huge everybody was talking everybody's
talking about it everybody did you see
it
they made a giant deal out of it and I
was like okay so if I say the planets
are aligned what would that mean to you
what do you think that means well for me
like just the intuitive thought would be
that you no out look up and you see a
line of dots in the sky the like they're
in you know in queue to come you know
get some ice cream or something in a
line or in a line planetary alignment
Okay so
so put a pin in that and consider the
following okay okay we have the sun in
the middle of
its own star system the solar system and
first out we have mercury then you have
Venus then you have Earth then you have
Mars then you have Jupiter then you have
Saturn and then you have Uranus and
Neptune okay right do you realize that
all of those planets orbit the Sun
in about the same plane right okay
so with like one giant pizza pie with
the sun in the middle okay okay so far
so good oh by the way Pluto orbits 30
degrees out of that plane one of the
many reasons why it does not belong
Among Us well you know because Pluto was
just like look I've marched to the beat
of my own drunk okay okay so therefore
you are your own damn
that's your own
Pluto has its own rhythms for sure right
all right so so everybody is orbiting
the same plane plane geometric plane
flattened plane around the solar system
and by the way everybody's moving in the
same direction which was a deep hint for
us to tell us how the solar system
formed
okay with like do these planets to fly
in randomly well if they did then they'd
have random orbits around the sun right
and then Bob so I'm going forward so I'm
going quote backwards so they all go in
the same direction and all in the same
plane and so it was concluded this is
now thinking that's been to 250 years
ago that maybe we started from a big gas
cloud that collapsed into this pancake
and in that pancake
the planets formed
with the sun in the middle that gets you
everybody orbiting in the same direction
and in the same plane okay so now let's
go down to earth
and look up into the sky where are you
going to find
all the planets
are you are they going to be everywhere
in the sky no no they're going to be on
the same plane
new plane as we are okay
so
not only that at any given moment at
night you're looking at half the sky
right
so on average half the stuff is going to
be in the sky when you're looking up
on average right
half the stuff okay because we are on a
ball
and so you're looking once again one
side of the ball and you see half of
what's out there seeing half the sky
because okay the other side of the ball
is looking at the other half of what's
up okay and you gotta wait till it's
night time for them but they see the
other half okay all right
half the sky
so
point is
of the planets including the Moon
okay which is also tilted a little out
of the plane but not enough to be
important for this example and the sun
is in the plane almost by definition
because while orbiting the Sun
okay
so
the CL the classical planets of
antiquity
which are all the objects that moved
against the background stars that
wandered the Greek word for Wanderer is
planetes which is where we get the word
planet and there were seven planets
the Sun
the moon Mercury Venus Mars Jupiter and
Saturn
and the seven days of the week
the names we give to the seven days of
the week are traceable
to the gods that oversaw those days
dating back to Greek and Roman
mythologies uh We've also touched with
Norse mythologies so the Norse
counterpart gods
to the Greek and Roman gods share the
same day
Okay
so Thursday is who's day Thor Thor Thor
Wheels the lightning bolt who in Roman
Legend the wheels lightning bolt uh Zeus
the Greek the Jupiter it was Roman so so
if you look at the romance languages the
word for Thursday is named for Jupiter
okay
and uh what is it uh in in Spanish no
Spanish
um Lunas martes Miracles whoever says
that's Jupiter okay okay it's named for
Jupiter that's why all the names of the
days of the week are capitalized they're
named after actual gods and planets and
things okay
point is
all of these objects in any given night
are always in a line
[Music]
period right
so it's I don't know how else to bring
the news to you
we are in the plane of the solar system
and we're looking out and we see other
objects in the plane of the solar system
and if you take a circle put it on its
side it's a line
there you go
so it's it's a news story that happens
every single night remember
in the news planetary alignment once
again once again so the way they try to
bump it up is if some planets are a
little closer to each other in our sight
line than at other months okay
so if they're a little closer then you
don't have to sort of turn your head
along the line to see them you might
catch them in one Glimpse okay fine
generally that is what they want to call
Planetary alignments but it leaves
people thinking that planets are not
aligned at any other time
whereas they are always aligned
right period period yes period
and the Moon is among them and the Moon
too the Moon is among them
so at any given night if you see the
Moon over here on the right and Venus
over there on the left make an arc
between them and complete that Arc
across the sky look for other planets on
that Arc and that you'll find you'll
find them you'll find them you'll find
Jupiter Saturn and if not that half of
the night wait to the other half of the
night right okay all right top story
tonight once again the planets decided
to line up
film at 11. okay now here's something
else they do they'll say
uh the planets are aligned and this
lineup will not repeat for another 150
000 years that's the one that happened
last year that everybody was going crazy
so you so you want to put that on your
calendar that's not going to repeat for
another 150 000 years well by the way
every night
for another 150 000 years whatever I
mean you can calculate what the it's the
point is
it's possible for something to be rare
and completely uninteresting
right
because every night is equally as rare
exactly
hey if we're all special nobody's
special then nobody's special right we
knew that we learned that from The
Incredibles right so I just trying to
put people say oh you're such a downer
new I put it on you know on social media
while you're such a downer right like
looking up there are other reasons to
look up right okay I don't have to fake
a reason for you to look up
um you know the asteroid might be coming
once you look up for that
all right no no don't look up
I saw that documentary a documentary
that's funny that's funny so that's all
I gotta say about about the planetary
alignment planetary alignments yeah just
chill
yeah there you go guys so it's it's BS
basically and because we're orbiting the
Sun we're always getting new angles on
how everybody's aligned and it's always
it's always new and it's not going to
repeat for hundreds of thousands of
years but every single day is that so
you know there it is by the way there is
something called a conjunction oh which
sounds like you need ointment for it
what's a function
yeah conjunction I got some ointment for
fix your conjunction all right uh make
sure you wash your hands if you get it
okay conjunction is you get like three
planets and I'll include the moon among
them as a classical planet that wanders
against the by the way they call them
Wanderers because they didn't understand
the physics of gravity right right after
Newton they they're not wandering at all
they know exactly what they're doing
exactly we actually know where they're
going and so do they right right so
nobody's wandering so so a conjunction
is when you have at least three objects
that are in the same part of the sky
where you can like you know
look through binoculars and all of them
are in one field of view we call those
conjunctions those are worth coming out
to check out
okay cool but this notion that of
alignment no and it's even made it into
our language oh uh things are going so
well the planets must have aligned right
it's it's worked its way into our
culture and
so you say yeah things work out for me
all the time because in fact the planets
are always aligned exactly
and also on the master of my own fate
you know
I would like to thank me
no no you get the you know the boxer who
wins it's like thank God right for right
for the ability to Pummel your other
person so they should go to the other
person and they're saying I blame God
just to thank God God hates me somebody
else want to get to blame God yeah I
lost because God hates me okay it's that
simple
if God liked me I wouldn't be here right
now yeah all right so there's been
another explainer nice all right take
that to the bank you got it this has
been another start talk explainer you
know the grass facing here as always
keep looking up
foreign